So far we've created our object and
built up the list of events to listen
for, let's figure out what happens
when we trigger one of those events.
We need a break point here so
that Chrome will pause when
we try to trigger the event.
These lines pull out
the arguments that are passed.
In our case that's an event, so
the arcs variable will be in a ray
with the string and event in it.
Then it calls the events API function,
just like it did when we used on.
This time trigger API will
be used as the iteratee.
Just like before, events API checks if
the event name is an object, a list,
or just a single word.
Then it calls iteratee,
which is the trigger API function.
Trigger API pulls the callback
out of the event object and
then passes the call back and
the arguments to trigger events.
Just like the on method,
most of the time is spent setting and
passing along data.
This function here is what actually
runs the callback function and the data.
This first line sets up
a bunch of local variables.
Then it checks how many
arguments were passed.
In our case that's just one,
so it jumps to here.
And it pulls out the event out of the
events array, gets the call back, and
calls it with the argument.
After that, Backbone just unwinds and
returns all the way up the chain.